this is madness the numbers are
overwhelming people here from all over
the world wanting to get out of Sudan as
soon as possible but struggling to find
a sustainable way to do so there have
been many promises that haven't been
fulfilled there have been many ships
that have come and gone three Saudi
vessels that have come and gone and none
of these people have managed to get on
it for several reasons many of them are
Sudanese they don't have the foreign
passport or residency in Saudi to get on
that ship but there are also people here
who just haven't who've just arrived who
haven't found the time to get the
documents that they need here is a desk
registering yemenis to go to Saudi the
last second to the second evacuation
vessel brought in 298 yemenis alone
there are many other yemenis that want
to go to Saudi you can see them fighting
you can just see the sheer chaos and on
everyone's face there's a sense of when
is this going to end we've left the hell
hole we've left on and we're still stuck
we're still unable to find a way to
safety we met people who are Syrian who
fled Civil War to come to Sudan and now
have found themselves
in another War fleeing Another War and
there are also Sudanese people here
who've left on their home for
generations to find life in another part
of the world sorry would you like to
speak sir where are you from I am in the
city you're from yemeni yes what are you
what are you planning to do what's your
we are
we are in a very dark situation here we
don't we don't really know what's the
plan to do we did we are in a poor
situation for organization from our
embassy it's not the real problem from
the government of the Saudis counseling
it's our problems our Embassy uh
planning for that we have seven here on
the very humidity under the suns the
Sudanese people I have been asked thank
you for them what was it like in Hartung
in Khartoum it's very bad like I cannot
even express that hard and harsh life to
live I mean that sound that
what I can explain it's a war you know
all about that and what were you hoping
to find here what brought you here I
brought here to go back home I don't
need even to go to Saudis I have my
emcee I have that's a lot for me and
take me as a really country so Saudi
will accept you as a yemeni yes accept
me why can't you get on a vessel
video
and it's a processing issue yes it's
about a planning issue from my position
our employment okay you sir
interminsteria
yeah where are you from I am from Yemen
awesome
just it's an English Channel but I want
to just ask this sir here yeah all of
these people are from Yemen people from
Surya it's just unbelievable it's people
who have fled conflict and have found
conflict again and and very little help
the humanitarian response is extremely
delayed the humanitarian groups the
agencies ngos the UN have evacuated
their staff and actually haven't created
a sustainable framework for the people
that they've Left Behind to either find
their way out or to find relief or to
get supplies we still haven't heard of
any convoys of humanitarian Aid getting
into hartum there is no humanitarian Aid
around have you guys
have you seen the U.N has anyone seen
the U.N here
they've said none of them have seen the
U.N here so people here are basically
been made to believe that they have to
get away from Sudan into safety by
themselves and the future looks
incredibly Bleak from where we stand